شماله كوسوفو عنوان توتر المتساعد منذ
ايام غير ان تفكيك حواجز ومتارس اقامها
سرب كوسوفو شمالا البلاد قد تفكك معها
ازمه خطيره تكاد تعصف بالمنطق
نظره حرب خيمه الايام الماضيه هنا في هذه
المنطقه جنوب شرقي اوروبا تحرك الجيش
الصربي وتاهب على الحدود قرب كسوفه ردت
كوسوفو باغلاق اكبر معبر حدود مع بلغراد
تاتي التطورات على خلفيه احتجاجات للصرد
في مدينه مترو فيتشا شمالي كوسوفو قطع
المحتجون الطرق منذ ثلاثه اسابيع
تصيد صربيا لم يخلو من رسائل تهديد واضحه
وربما ابعد فالغرب
جديده في المنطقه كما يدرك ان ثمه توريطا
اخر يلوح في الافق تبدو روسيا حاضره وبقوه
فالرئيس الصربي حليف لروسيا والاخيره لم
تتاخر في اعلان دعمها لصربيها في الازمه
الراهنه وهو ما يشير ربما بدور روسي
فتطورات الاخيره
لمعهد كارنيجي التقرير ذهب ايضا الى ان
روسيا تسعى الى فتح جبهه جديده ضد الغرب
في الخاصره الاوروبيه الضعيفه بمنطقه
البلقان
الموقف الغربي المطالب بالامتناع عن
الاستفزاز وتهديدات واعمال الترهيب دعا
الى نزع فتيل التوتر وضبط النفس من دون
شروط
تهدئه ربما غير ان الاوضاع هناك تبقى
مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات في بؤره تغذيها
ازمات معقده تاريخيا قد تنفجر في اي لحظه